etwas ganz cool war als 100 zu springen
wie so ein gangster das hat das hat der
glp er das auch einfach gemacht aber so
ein bungee jump gemacht ich bin schon
und ich habe extra
[Musik]
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu minecraft warum
dieser folge wollen wir umziehen und
mittlerweile auch kellers hallo
ja ja der typ der typ der die basis
geplündert hat durch lincoln durch
doktor.de dort böse der antichrist ich
weiß es nicht 8 sogar all ich glaube
dass man die letzten auch dieser
kompletten map das ganze web abgesucht
ohnehin alles alle was carla dessen
leben auch im urlaub einfach gesucht ist
es einfach noch mal ein paar diamanten
oben drauf dann kann ich mal wieder nach
oben
ich weiß jetzt natürlich nicht leute
wenn ihr jetzt unter der letzten folge
total böse war hat und ich mich zum
weinen gebracht hat und ich seit drei
stunden sprechen kann weil ich einem
heulkrampf bin dann tut mir das sehr
leid für mein zukünftiges selbst aber
ich denke das wird alles cool gewesen
sondern habe ich doch einfach nicht
gewachsen
das ist nicht cool das ist gar nicht
cool
vielleicht können wir ja ein bisschen
mit eisen aufstocken ab wann haben wir
jetzt genug
ich hätte natürlich noch weiter gucken
können weil vielleicht hat er auch noch
eine kiste gewesen aber vielleicht wurde
das reisen auch einfach vergessen weil
da war halt ich nix mehr darum hätte ich
mich doch weiter der basis um schauen
sollen durch dafür überhaupt an dem von
lorne das passt ja schon aber ich habe
mich auch gar nicht irgendwie bewusst
dahin gegraben ich wusste nicht mal wo
genau die da waren
ich habe es richtig voll okay das werk
zuvor den frauen sind es durch die welt
und fällt auf einmal so ein loch in
dessen labors
so sollen etwa war dasselbe was ich in
einer höhle habe ich die werke klatschen
dann sah ich dort die casting table und
die hilfen
aber da müssen wir jetzt auch immer
daran denken dass wir das zeug aus
unseren höfen wirklich protector
testreihe tun damit es das halt nicht
selbst passiert irgendwann mal habe ich
überhaupt gesagt ich bin nicht mehr ich
bin wirklich gespannt bei wem bei wem
wir das geklärt haben ob das jetzt
möglich bei simon war also es kam mir
vor als es ist ein bisschen so aus wie
david handel und jemand im raum gerannt
sind
aber das werde man ja wären wir noch
früh genug erfahren gar nicht dass hier
alles so stehen lassen ohne dass das
hier die ganze zeit abbricht
jetzt werden wir ich will ich will auch
gar nicht dass man das in die conti
gleicht reinschreiben sodann für 48
eisen die herzlich sondern einfach so
geschehen lassen weil ich das dann
irgendwie dann auf einmal in unsere
wieder wenn das wirklich wie man es war
das wieder so sagen danke simon danke
für die gute die eisen weil das was ich
da so sagt sowie waren das dann guckt
also videos dürfen sich an unsere basis
also wir sind da natürlich schon
umgezogen aber trotzdem dass die ganzen
hass auf und pflegen ja also obwohl uns
jetzt dazu sagen wenn man ja einmal
schon eine gute aktion hat es ist jetzt
also werden diamanten gewesen wärst
deutlich deutlich deutlich schlimmer
also dann wäre es ja ich denke auch das
ist alles relativ wenig war das war das
nicht das ist das was anderes
ich bin jetzt hallo eine koordinate ich
mir nutzen ich bin ich ich hoffe ich
finde schon zurück aber ich bin halt ein
mega in der in der in der pampa ja ich
geh doch mal wieder zurück ich bin ich
bin so oft einfach nur die ganze zeit
unter tage und das will ich eigentlich
gar nicht weil man sieht in meinen
folgen immer nur graue glocke und und
meine fresse und ich weiß nicht was da
von hessischer ist jetzt beleidigt ich
mich ja jetzt ich hab da ein bisschen
nicht wechselt einmal so ein bisschen
durch entweder man abwägen von ohnehin
so traurig ist so richtig traurig bild
zu malen einfach gar nichts kino sieht
wirklich noch mal rein ich spüre dass
das hier nochmal wir müssen nochmal
irgendwo ein paar diaz zu holen sein
das kann ja wohl nicht angehen dass ich
hier jetzt schon nach zwei minuten ja
ich habe wirklich in fast jeder folge
diamanten gefunden bisher infekt gar nix
ich kann nix worüber ein ja gar nichts
gar nichts mehr ein okay kaum ist echt
traurig kam shawn chapman holley am mont
in moshi moshi moshi ja wir haben aber
18 leder das ist schon mal da ich sing
und sind einfach diamanten was ist denn
los doch es sind zwar nur zwei aber
immerhin besser als nichts wir können
uns auch gleich von tnt machen
jetzt habe ich das ist gut ich habe auch
ein bisschen was von keeper dann bin ich
jetzt bei
ach so dann hast du schon zwei diamant
eile für eine rüstung je 1 du hast nur
schulgeld ja also entweder mache ich
wäre dann jetzt gleich hier soll ich
noch mal komme ich mache mal 22 streifen
euch nochmal rein vielleicht findest du
wirklich noch welche wenn du noch welche
findet dann ist es unglaublich
das ist so das so spürsinn weiß ja dass
server hat mich einfach lieben er will
mit mir bin mit mir ganz viel liebe
machen wenn ich mal mit dem kinde zeug
dann mit diesem server ja ich poste die
arbeit jetzt bin ich wieder dieser höhle
von denen gelandet ist ja wohl ein witz
wir haben nur drei wolle das ist schade
weil sonst könnten wir noch zu
überspringen naja aber es ist ja auch
ein bisschen spannender wenn wir hier
wirklich so die die zwei jahresmieten
paris bei nacht durch die gegend baumeln
brokeback mountain reloaded man bei
kupferstecher meinig wurden stecher
sagen geht muss man muss mit dem
kosenamen völlig aus denken sogar auf
jeden fall ich fühle mich ja auch immer
so ein bisschen als impressionist einmal
sortiert ne ja gut dass du das gemacht
also die wichtigen sachen immerhin die
in die projekte together auf jeden fall
und jetzt war es war richtig viele
suppen und meine spieler alles kaputt ja
ich würde schon gern jetzt um ein paar
diamanten finden ist ja nicht so dass da
ist man auch unsere wissen die amanda
rausch drin ich habe ein ganz wertvoller
so für eine spitzhacke also es reicht
knapp aus meissen ich weiß es nicht
reichen 60 einen für die spezies ist
knapp noch weiß es nicht geht auf jeden
fall schon abschätzen
ich habe 24 stakes und ein halbes invent
a chip für dich da sollten ärzte sollte
es eigentlich nicht scheitern
also jetzt kommt es jetzt server server
konzentriere dich nochmal matthias
kommen nur noch nur noch 1 2 war dann
kann ich mir nicht mehr schuhe machen
und du kannst dir ein helm machen oder
so heißt das nicht sogar aus für das
tierchen die rechtlich aus aber noch
nicht volle rüstungs punkte neben mir
fehlen wir viel noch 22 rüstungs punkte
fehlen
wir wollten in dieser folge umziehen ja
stimmt da nur neun minuten weil ich
mache ich nur waren abdullah abdullah
ist schon wieder nacht ich mache nur
denen den strike vielleicht nur zwei und
fertig
es ist erst gut weiß ich nicht es war
kurzum ein bisschen gucken dass er sein
lud auch an die an die muskulären
bedingungen anpasst ja ich meine
theoretisch müssten einfach nur zwei
berge wegziehen dass ich meine das ist
das was die zuschauer werden denen ja
die koordinaten wenn schon sagen sogar
die sind bei x50 und y 30 aber wenn wir
dann bei x7 50 sind und 19 37h 14
blötter weg und da wird er dann kein
anderer so drin graben
die haben eh schon wieder irgendwie
würde gelernt das liegt doch gar nicht
ich bin raus kommen wir müssen jetzt
hier meine warte warte hier
ich spüre ich spüre dass ich spüre dass
ich nehme schon mal die wichtigsten
sachen mit praktisch schon ein bisschen
ein
ich glaube dass ich gewinnen jetzt macht
macht mir schon mal den du noch fertig
berlin ein sagen wir ja diese scheiss
kiste können wir einfach hier lassen
ich will trotzdem sagen dass wir die
abbauen die kiste dass die ganze zeit
das halt in der lava fallen oder nicht
dass da hier irgendwer da bin ich hoch
geklettert okay gut oder oder ist das
die band ihr hoch geklettert oder war
das ist dass das von mir das ist meins
gut jetzt ich dachte schon wieder ich
werde wieder in irgendeiner basis der
basis reingestolpert aber acht die
jahres ist okay die verliere ich jetzt
raus lassen von dem skelett töten oder
das projekt auch zu ende wenn ich ganz
gut so einfach zehn creeper einkommen
für hätten und wir sterben man muss man
muss ja mit erfolgen anzahl muss man
auch nicht immer übertreiben luca was du
willst du willst hier das ist ja stimmt
jesus cool wenn man direkt sterben würde
aber wie schafft es diese kaká steht
hier kann das sein dass das nur bei tag
wächst ich weiß auch wenn es draußen
steht ich war ich weiß ich habe keiner
weil es ist einfach kein bisschen
gewachsen
hier sind zwei kripo im gebäude um
[Musik]
doch als es gerade gewachsen
schön
ich habe das ist ein paar einfache
explosion nebenan ich doch er läuft auch
das muss es war so ein bisschen schöner
ausblick basiere die wand hier sieht sie
doch würde die wird kommen jetzt ja ich
um entschuldigung riese umziehen
ein bisschen für ein bisschen dramatik
muss muss sein weiß wofür auch
seinerzeit allerdings müsste man hat
muss man echt eine bessere verbindung zu
legen da kommen schon wieder hallo
zombies na wat los
die verbindung kommt wochen mächtig
nähert sich nicht vielleicht kannst du
ja auch weiblichen hde schmuggel von
stream so was hab ich da mitnehmen was
wie wo was soll ich damit nehmen wir
müssen nicht alles gefallen nur die
rechte kiste mehr nicht die ganzen höfen
und die chance habe ich schon morgen hin
obwohl ich hier erstmal zeug raus dass
ich halt nicht braucht ja wie man es
halt jeden fall bevor wir diese
folgezeit mich schon wieder drei neue
folgende aufnehmen und weiterleiten
können wir uns irgendwie in wien
backpack machen oder so wie ging das
dann kann man nicht anders verhält
eine tolle stelle wo wir hingehen das
ist halt einfach nur ein bisschen weiter
jetzt also ich sage mal alles ein was
irgendwie
drin ist ja ja aber was ich halt was ich
habe warum kann man den die pilzsuppe
nicht stapeln
willst du dir nicht mal witze gehe ich
gleich mal ein helm machen oder so ja
wenn du diamanten hätte es dann ja ja
die kann ich dir geben aber gucken mal
wieder rein und ich sitzen doch jetzt um
die haben wir noch fünf ja ich weiß aber
was hast du die ich kann nicht alles
mitnehmen was in der kiste ist ja du ich
bin ja auch fast voll
du bist immer viel mit sie könne auch
nur zweimal laufen das wäre vielleicht
sogar eine ganz gute idee irgendwie
zweimal zu laufen ich nehme es noch so
viele pilze suchen mit wie geht wir
müssen ja auch nicht so weit weg
ja genau das dass man einfach dass man
einfach weggehen und wiederkommen kann
man wieder wurde die koordinaten davon
sind ich weiß es nicht sogar hier kommen
wir heute wohnt ja wohl dass irgendwann
irgendwann hole mir das wieder so ich
komme nicht doch in dieser folge auf
jeden fall noch in dieser folge okay wir
haben noch zeit findet also ich würde
einfach sagen dass wir wirklich hier
oder so einfach hin das ist ja relativ
egal ich meinen die leute sehen ja diese
folge quasi er suspendiert schon wieder
zwei neue aufgenommen und wieder ein
bisschen sind ich würde hier so hin da
hinten ja dann lasst dahin kommt wo bist
du denn hier
wenn nicht dann eigentlich wo bist du
denn das ist etwas ganz cool darunter zu
springen wie so ein gangster das hat das
hat der gpa das auch aber gemacht da hat
einfach so ein bungee jump gemacht ich
bin schon und ich habe extra frei
gebrochen so gut
egal wir haben sie ja geht das wir haben
sie die medizinische abteilung muss ist
allererste sahne alles alles okay gehen
uns nicht alles so schön hier ist
richtig hell und freundlich dann hat
sich meine zuschauer komme ich schmerzen
weil die ganze liste konstanz konstant
weg hier was geht mit euch alles alles
alles schritt alles fit schritt
was geht ja doch woraufhin wir müssen
jetzt langsam hier ne yo check
durchlaufen hat es ist ein psycho 2002
creeper hinter die kinos ich guck dir
mal zu dir mal drei hallo hallo hallo
hallo wir sind überall zombies einfach
kommt ihr das mal seid ihr hier
achtung explodieren explodieren geweckte
weg geweckt die werke wird ganz ruhig
und ruhig alles gut alles gut
drücken wir das auch mal eine gute
taktik alles alles gut alles gut
zurück ist einfach eine wand einfach
zombie gemetzel hier am start wieder
bisschen ein bisschen pvp dort vier
minuten wir müssen noch eine neue basis
machen und jetzt lasst mal einfach das
war einfach dass es unglaublich dass
einfach keine basis finden ja ja ja ja
ja ich finde das unglaublich dass man
einfach jetzt hier rein das ist ja
relativ egal jetzt erstmal okay okay
lass das hier rein passt mal auf das hat
keine zombies sind oder so ja da ist
einer kommt jetzt täglich mit einem
heber teile verschwinden würdig hast du
eine fackel
ja natürlich ich hab so ganz viele folge
kozak und zeigen machen auch schon mal
ein schild so jedoch nicht nach der
ersten skizze machen muss ja muss ja
immer das war dumm aber hier geht es
wieder raus ja dann bauen wir das halt
wieder zu das ist ja egal wir bleiben da
eh nicht so lange jetzt war der wahl was
ich mache ich mach dich mal dass ich
wollte das optimal mit einer sexuell
nicht durchziehen
naja ich bin ich bin ich immer schon
hatte ich brauch schon die basis jemand
dass nur ich mach das so ein bisschen
schöner als du weißt du musst ja auf die
ästhetik achten das ist es zu dunkel in
den videos
jetzt schon wieder hinkommen hier lässt
sich doch lieben kommen da lässt sich
aushalten
ein kleines süßes kämmerchen für uns
zwei entspannt oder luca hier hier gehen
wir an
ja hier gehen wir rein dazu hat eine
ganze sache diamanten mögliche oktober
hinter ihnen
ich habe so wenig eisen erstmal darum
kümmern uns echt zum kotzen
auch holzspielzeuge mitgenommen dass es
dumm gewesen so oder so keine zeit mehr
ja das ist ja auch okay man muss ja
nicht immer zeit haben im leben du und
wir müssen diese folge auf jeden fall
auch alles von uns helfen dass du das
alles ist da drüben oder gewesen so
moment das war auch weil wir dann ganz
schön knappes ding hier von unserem
von unserem warum redet von mir der
dritten person
ich weiß es nicht dass man vielleicht
die psychisch gestört die leute kinos
psychotisch sich heute heute werden wir
müssen das ja auch irgendwie abriegeln
aber das ist gar nicht hier haben wir
gar nicht gewohnt
er war mit den gewohnt conny ich bin
schon wieder zu hause
aber da können wir nicht mal darum gehen
wir zurück da wo wir jetzt sind und ich
habe mich aber instabil und des bundes
also ein bisschen aber wir sind bei 14
minuten
okay ich mache ich mach das so damit man
dass ich sie ja schon wieder so knapp
den sprung nicht immer hält sich
übermütig du wie ich irgendwie stecken
kann man noch mal ich hab ich habe weiß
ich schon ich glaube unsere basis hin
dass ich hab wirklich hab den
orientierungssinn von einer dementen
großmutter auf krieg das ist also da da
braucht gar nicht viel und ich war ich
habe aber jetzt schon ich weiß auch
nicht mehr unser neuer basis ist
vollständig jetzt hast du dich wirklich
verlaufen
ich bin schon in dem bereich aber ich
glaube ich weiß es jetzt weiter ich muss
gucken jetzt gefunden ja ich habe uns
dann macht das irgendwie so dass man das
nicht sieht weil ich bin auch wieder ein
30 sekunden bin ich da ein 30 sekunden
also damit wirklich 30 sekunden und hast
du nicht kannst erzählen wo warst du
letzten acht
bei dir da gibt es zu 30 sekunden
was mache ich denn hier ist ist
konkreter eine dreckige [ __ ] rosa bin
von der loggia irgendwie zu ich bin ja
das bin was du sagst du im lokal zu ich
bin gerade dran und ich sterbe ich
glaube haben schon fast genug
bücherregal ist also nicht so gemacht
geht aus doch hab ich doch gleich war
das dauert das muss hier im ofen gucke
23 sekunden erledigt cook 1 hier meine
ich aber einfach wir wollen ich mache
ich mal von dem schild dran du du ich
glaube wir können sogar schon auf
höheren level nach ebern weiter können
schon bücherregale bücherregal ein paar
bücherregale machen und dann ist das
cool weil sich ja wenn man glaube ich
schon ein bücherregal rumstehen hat dann
kann man schon auf level 4 verzaubern
ich packte er sehr wichtigen sache
informiert du dich da mal du kleiner
minecraft juli haben keine zeit nicht
dass wir darüber ziehen wir sind wieder
wer 60 meint ich meine dass du dich dass
du dass du dir das später überlegst du
kannst du mal von pfarrer untergehen in
einem feuchten träume ich diesmal vom
server herunter weil papa das so sagt
last eine positive wertung da wir sehen
uns nächste folge wieder
dann bringt euch jetzt zum beispiel auch
nicht dass wir den leuten in die
kommentare dazu schreiben wo wir sind
weil wir da wieder umgezogen sind egal